as an immigrant from chile pierre bravo
spent many years undocumented and in the
shadows she worked odd jobs to pay her
way through school before finding an
opening in the media industry and
eventually becoming a reporter on msnbc
in her new book the other how to own
your power at work as a woman of color
she writes about her journey and the
lessons she's learned along the way
daniela pierre-bravo good morning to you
thank you for being here good morning
thank you so much for having me you know
what i love about the book is that you
talk about as an immigrant that there
are really great things about entering
the workplace of hustling and having
this work ethic but then you talk about
how that can
change and it's not so great anymore
yeah well the immigrant ethos is a
beautiful thing right my mom and my
grandma always taught me to put my head
down and do the work right be grateful
for everything it's the energy that got
me from undocumented to be able to go to
college to getting on an 18 hour bus
ride because i lied on my resume and
said that i lived in new york just that
i could get an opportunity to get an
unpaid internship
but you know by the same token when we
advance in our career especially for
women of color when we're constantly
leading with that overly grateful
mentality to the point where we fear
asking for more because we don't want to
be ungrateful it can kind of not work in
our favor and by the way if you put your
head down and do the work in corporate
america if you don't let people know
what you're doing yeah no one's going to
notice that you got to brag about
yourself a little bit don't be humble uh
the book uh speaking of not being humble
i'll not be humble for you you got a
great voice uh you got a delicate touch
it's gonna help a lot of people uh and
you describe a moment in the book it's
sort of part career advice uh and then
part memoir and in the memoir part you
talk about a breaking point for yourself
when you started thinking about change
can you talk about that breaking point
yeah i think for a lot of women of color
we experience this breaking point of
burnout
and you know for a lot of our
communities we have been in constant
survival mode that fight or flight is
very familiar to us so we tend to find
and recreate those moments in our career
to the point where we feel like our
worth
is predicated on our productivity and
it's hard for us to shift that mindset
and we know that as women go on in their
careers we need to play by different
rules we can't be constantly in that
customer service mentality
and it's hard because that means that we
need to say no to some things that we
advise we do that and it's hard right
and especially for women of color
because we don't want to cause that
cognitive dissonance we don't want to
put people at this ease but it's so
important as we move along in our career
you know i really try to cheerlead other
women yeah but i even find it hard to
cheerlead myself what are some tips for
people that you would if you're speaking
to other women that you give them yeah i
mean i think that you know
we're so lucky now especially gen z as
we as we you know as they come up in the
workplace gen z is going to be the most
diverse generation out there and when
i think about as
a woman of color who is sometimes the
one and only in a room it's not just
about me
right it's about the advocating that i
do for myself but the the the more room
that i leave for other women behind us
and i think that's important that we're
not just cheerleading ourselves and it's
not just about us but it's about the
door that we leave even wider for the
women after us yeah pay matters pay
negotiations yeah yeah uh what tips do
you have on that front and are you right
about why even if you get a no at first
you shouldn't stop it no yeah there's a
lot of great tips on negotiation in the
book but that's exactly right it's so
important to not leave that negotiation
and just assume the no is forever so
what you want to do is you want to make
sure to talk to your manager and say
okay what are the metrics that i missed
and what are the qualifications and the
metrics that you're looking for so that
they meet them and make sure that you
don't leave there without putting a time
on their calendar whether it's three or
six months to have this conversation to
check in because you don't want to wait
a full year for the next performance
review yeah you really have to know your
worth though sometimes that can be
really hard yeah well that's why it's so
important to talk about it and talk
about it often you know in this remote
work kind of life that we're going
through it's even more important it's
it's more than okay it's necessary and
you know it's hard to be a manager at
this time there's a lot of things that
they're juggling so
help them help you and one way by doing
that is to make sure that you're having
consistent conversations whether it be
weekly or bi-weekly about what are the
wins that you're bringing to the table i
like that a lot daniella prier bravo
thank you so much for being here we
really appreciate it so much the other
how to own your power at work as a woman
of color goes on sale tomorrow you can
pick it up